foreign
um
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
absolutely
foreign
example
foreign
[Music]
80 Seconds
foreign
affairs
Mr Nice Brown United Nations
humanitarian coordinator in Ukraine
it is so decided
to the United Nations to participate in
this meeting
it is so decided
the security Council
it's consideration of item two of the
agenda Carla
foreign
Mr President
the situation for civilians in Ukraine
remains dire
as of 18 October the office of the High
Commissioner for human rights has
recorded 15
956 civilian communities
6 322 killed and
9634 injured since 24 February 2022.
at least 397 children have been killed
in the war since 24 February
the actual figures are likely
considerably High
in a recent and concerning development
the Russian Federation launched a series
of attacks against cities and towns
across the country
on the morning of 10 October Russian
Armed Forces reportedly launched
missiles and drones killing at least 20
civilians in injuring over 100 including
in Kiev nipro and South parisia
many civilian objects including dozens
of residential buildings physical
infrastructure were damaged
in total between 10 and 18 October at
least 38 Ukrainian civilians orderedly
killed in at least 117 injured by
missile and drone attacks
in addition to immediate loss of life
the United names is greatly concerned
about the destruction of critical energy
infrastructure such as power plants
according to the Ukrainian government
percent of energy facilities have been
hit since 10 October
combined with soaring gas and coal
prices the definition caused by these
attacks threatens to expose millions of
civilians to extreme hardship and even
life endangering conditions this winter
to be clear under International
humanitarian law attacks targeting
civilians and civilian infrastructure
are prohibited
so our attack against military
objectives that may be expected to cause
harm to civilians that would be
excessive in relation to the concrete
and direct military Advantage
anticipated
Mr President the United Nations
continues to support all efforts towards
accountability
it's essential
which CHR be given complete and
unimpeded access to all areas of Ukraine
to continue its crucial work
for its part the independent
International Commission of inquiry on
Ukraine submitted its report to the
general assembly this week
the document states that there are real
grounds to conclude that war crimes and
violations of human rights and
international humanitarian law have been
committed in Ukraine since 24 February
22.
the commission stated that Russian
troops were responsible for the vast
majority of the violations identified
and also stated
that Ukrainian armed forces have also
committed International humanitarian law
violations in some cases including two
incidents bellify as war crimes
according to the commission Relentless
use of explosive weapons with wide area
effects in popular areas has killed and
injured scores of civilians in
devastated entire neighborhoods foreign
Additionally the commission documented
patterns of summary executions on lawful
confinement torture ill treatment rape
and other sexual violence committed in
areas occupied by Russian offices
the impact of these violations on the
people in Ukraine is immense
and so is the need for accountability
in this regard the commission called for
a sound coordination of the multiple
National and international
accountability initiatives in Ukraine
accountability remains crucial as new
allegations of atrocities have emerged
in areas that have recently returned to
Ukrainian government control
we must not let impunity prevail
Mr President we welcome the announcement
on Monday of another exchange of
prisoners of war between Ukraine and the
Russian Federation
110 Russian captives were exchanged for
108 ukrainians
this was the first change in which all
freed ukrainians were women among them
civilians military personnel and
National and Border guards
building constructive Spirit of the
prisoner exchanges I want to reiterate
the secretary General's appeal to the
Russian Federation to Grant full access
to the internet Committee of the Red
Cross to all prisoners of war in
accordance with International
humanitarian law
Mr President
IAL impact of the war in Ukraine is
substantial and growing
the U.N has detailed its impact on food
security energy and finance
the Black Sea Green initiative has
helped to bring down food prices and
stabilize and subsequently lower Global
food prices and move grain from the
world's bread baskets to those in need
as of 19 October the total tonnage of
grain and other foodstuffs exported
through the initiative had reached
almost 8 million metric tons
to maintain food security worldwide it
is critical that the initiative be
extended Beyond
it is equally critical that there be
uninvuted access to Russian food and
fertilizers
the United Nations will spare no effort
to which rate of food security for all
populations
Mr President we're on a path of further
escalation which can only cause more
suffering people of Ukraine Russia and
the rest of the world
this trajectory must be reversed
any suggestions of the possibilities of
nuclear or other non-conventional
weapons only serves to further heighten
tensions and could lead to a dangerous
spiral
any damage to this operation nuclear
power plant whether intentional or by
accident could have catastrophic
consequences
any military against Frome or near the
site must cease immediately
Mr President the general assembly has
been clear last assembly stated that the
referendums held in the region of
Ukraine that are or have been under
temporary military control of the
Russian Federation
subsequent attempted illegal annexations
of these regions have no validity
validity under international law and do
not form the base for any alteration of
the status of these regions of Ukraine
this week the Russian Federation
announced the introduction of Martial
law regions of Ukraine under its
temporary military control
and that it has attempted to illegally
Annex
this decision combined with the
Annunciation in her son amid intensified
fighting on the ground raises serious
concerns
Mr President the general assembly almost
pressed strong support for the
de-escalation of the current situation
and a peaceful solution of the conflict
through political dialogue negotiation
negation and other powerful means
peaceful means with respect for the
sovereignty and territorial Integrity of
Ukraine within its internationally
recognized borders and in accordance
with the principles of the charter
indeed an end to the war founded on
international law and the charter is the
surest way to ensure that the tremendous
suffering of the civilians in Ukraine
will cease thank you Mr President
Brown
Mr President I will speak briefly about
the human toll of this war the new
dimensions of the humanitarian crisis
and the challenge of access to
non-government-controlled areas
deaths and suffering of civilians
ravaged urban and rural areas and total
loss of livelihood for Millions this is
the impact of the war on the civilian
population of Ukraine now in its 239th
day
the people of Ukraine are under
tremendous stress mental health issues
are emerging and this will be one of the
most devastating and longer lasting
legacies of this war
I was recently in mikolaibo Blast where
the mayor told me that since the 24th of
February they have only had 33 days of
Silence
33 days without explosions and Air Raid
Sirens let's do the math
that comes to only one day a week with
no reprieve from The Sounds in the
terror let alone the physical toll of
the war
the sheer depth of the humanitarian
catastrophe is staggering almost 18
million people more than 40 percent of
the entire Ukrainian population need
humanitarian assistance
some 14 million have been forced to flee
their homes including 6.2 million
internally displaced and nearly 7.7
million refugees according to UNICEF
some 5.7 million school-aged children
have been affected since the start of
the war including 3.6 million due to the
closure of educational institutions the
world health organizations says there
have been more there have been over 630
verified attacks on Health Care
Facilities barring the sick from
medicines and treatment
the gender and protection dimensions of
this crisis while extremely sensitive
are great and need to be addressed
through strengthened programming and
monitoring
Mr President with each passing day we
Face New Dimensions to the monetarying
crisis first temperatures are plummeting
in Ukraine as winter approaches the
destruction of Civilian infrastructure
has recently become more widespread
energy Supply telecommunications and
transport infrastructure have been in
some areas devastated affecting people's
access to water electricity and heat and
their ability to communicate
the damage to power and thermal plants
means that life will be even harder for
the already vulnerable including elderly
people and those with disabilities there
is also an increased risk of death in
the months ahead because civilians may
not have access to the essential
Services services to survive
International humanitarian law is very
clear attacks must never be directed
against civilians or civilian objects
and constant care must be taken to spare
them
to address essential needs we the United
Nations and humanitarian Community have
developed a specific plan for the winter
months built at the Obelisk level in
coordination with the authorities and in
close collaboration with the government
focuses on collector Center and
household repairs and the provision of
blankets mattresses clothes food
generators for schools and much needed
thermal heating for hospitals
work is underway the aim is for
civilians to have a safe dignified and
warm place to be over the winter months
despite the challenges we are helping
people already this year more than 590
humanitarian partners are now delivering
critical assistance and protection
Countrywide many of them are national
and local Aid organizations women-led
organizations and volunteers who are at
the Forefront of these efforts we must
commend their leadership bravery and
commitment
together we have reached over 13 million
people across the country and we
continue to explore options for reaching
others where the need is greatest
second newly accessible areas means that
we can reach entirely new communities
with humanitarian assistance and
essential Services Aid workers are
acting quickly to reach those in need
taking into consideration the security
risks while upholding our commitment to
stay and deliver
however inaccessible areas of kharkif
Carson and Donetsk the threat of
landmines and unexploded ordinance
contamination hinders humanitarian
operations the immediate priority for
the humanitarian mine Action Center
sector must be to prevent civilian
casualties from explosive Ordnance and
to help enable the safe delivery of
humanitarian relief
third psychosocial trauma the Ministry
of Health and who estimate that close to
10 million people will need some kind of
Psychosocial support due to the trauma
from this war this includes women and
girls suffering sexual violence and
other forms of gender-based violence
children hearing warnings Sirens daily
families who have been separated or
people just trying to survive every day
in areas where the government of Ukraine
has regained control particularly in
rural areas civilians who have witnessed
or experienced terrible violations on
ongoing hostilities are among the most
at risk just a few weeks ago I visited
the community of balaclia in the newly
accessible District of izum in the
kharkiv oblast
the majority of those who remained were
very old people and those who stayed
behind to care for them and who were
unable to flee the area
the U.N and our partners are working to
strengthen our capacity to address the
growing psychosocial needs of Ukraine
humanitarian access to those most in
need has been a consistent challenge in
this conflict
right now one of the most significant
challenges remains access to parts of
the Nets Carson luhansk and zapritia we
are extremely concerned about the people
in these territories who we cannot reach
regular requests continue to be made to
cross the front line yet we are not
receiving the necessary agreement from
all parties
operationally we are ready to move with
interagency convoys and Aid Personnel
into
non-government-controlled areas
the consequences of not delivering
assistance to the estimated millions of
people in these areas are dire
particularly with the winter months
already upon us we must be able to
alleviate the human suffering caused by
this war International humanitarian law
which already embodies a balancing act
between humanity and Military necessity
clearly requires parties to allow and
facilitate the rapid and unimpeded
passage of humanitarian relief for all
civilians in need and through all
possible routes
obstructions that leave the civilian
population without the essentials to
survive run contrary to this obligation
finally The Flash appeal has seen
unprecedented donor support
more than US dollar 2.9 billion has been
received against requirements of 4.3
billion for this year
this is second most funded country level
appeal in un history only behind Yemen
in 2019 at 3.6 billion US dollars
the Ukraine humanitarian fund has also
received significant new funding with
more than 230 million in contributions
and pledges of that 117 million dollars
has already been dispersed and we have
now included 20 million dollars for the
local volunteer organizations
I think the donors for their generous
support
in closing the people of Ukraine have
shown incredible resilience in this last
year
our urgent humanitarian task is to
continue to help them to survive and to
be safe thank you Mr President
I think um
who wish to make statements
to the representative of Mexico
thank you very much Mr President
under Secretary General
resident and humanitarian coordinator in
Ukraine Ms Brown thank them for their
briefings
as we have heard
in Ukraine has had a devastating impact
on the civilian population
figures continue to rise the numbers of
dead people and wounded people continue
to grow
civilian victims that is and everything
suggests that these figures will
continue again to rise
if something more effective and Urgent
is not done
more than 17 million people require
humanitarian Aid more than seven million
there are more than seven million
refugees in European countries and there
are more than six million in in
displaced internally displaced persons
and it looks very much like winter will
make this scenario far more complex and
immediate action will be required the
indiscriminative attacks that have taken
place in recent days against civilian
infrastructure including those using
unmanned aerial Vehicles
International humanitarian law
dimensions of the humanitarian crisis
consequently continue to remain on an
alarming scale it is for this reason
that Mexico together with France called
for this meeting that is to analyze
the recent dimensions of the problem and
to attempt to provide Solutions and
Alternatives
adherence to the Norms of international
humanitarian law including the Geneva
conventions of 1949 and their additional
protocols
is an obligation without exceptions
the provisions of these instruments are
unequivocally clear
parties must make a clear distinction
between the civilian population and
combatants
moreover it is forbidden to use weapons
or methods of War which may cause
unnecessary losses are excessive
suffering
the principles of necessity and
proportionality must always be
stringently adhered to the impact of
this conflict on Health Care Services as
we have heard has been very grave indeed
according to the World Health
Organization
more than 630 attacks have been recorded
against Ukraine's Health Care System
deliberate attacks against hospitals
war crimes they are unacceptable and
they cannot go unpunished
the conflict has also had a grave impact
on the mental health of the population
and that will leave a indelible mark on
vast sways of the population affected
both directly and indirectly
psychosocial support must consequently
be a non-negotiable component of
humanitarian assistance
moreover we are alarmed by reports on
sexual violence and gender-based
violence all such cases must be
investigated to ensure accountability
and to ensure effective redress is
provided to the victims and this must be
done with a gender perspective
faced with challenges of this size
fighting underway is affecting the
capacity that humanitarian actors have
to operate on the ground it is of the
utmost importance to guarantee
unfettered humanitarian access such that
crucial Services can be provided to
those that need them and this in line
with the basic principles of humanity
neutrality
impartiality and Independence
the significant mobilization of donors
who have helped to finance the
humanitarian response in Ukraine however
as is always the case
needs are for outweighing finance at
this time
it is likely that the civilian
population's vulnerability will increase
in the coming months with the arrival of
winter and given the serious damage done
to energy infrastructure as such
colleagues it is urgent that attacks
against civilian infrastructures
moreover the presence of mines in
Ukraine is also a source of grave
concern because in addition to their
impacts on the civilian population in
particular on girls and boys the
presence of these devices affects the
humanitarian communities ability to
operate safely of course
they pose grave risks too in the medium
and long term
urgent designing work does not get
underway the Ukraine's agricultural
sector will face grave challenges in the
next sowing season as such we urge
parties to reach an agreement which will
make it possible to renew the Black Sea
grain initiative that initiative has
been crucial in mitigating the impact of
this war on Global Food security
Mr President my country repudiates in
the strongest possible terms any threat
of the use of nuclear weapons
and as such it is timely to recall the
communique released in January in which
nuclear weapon States stated
is that a nuclear war must never be
fought
in this same vein it is regrettable that
we have not yet seen the establishment
of a safety militarized zone around the
nuclear power plant in zapposia and this
in spite of the recommendations issued
by the iaea
and also in spite of the appeals
launched by the Secretary General and
the International Community we urge
parties to heed this these appeals
urgently I would conclude that the most
effective way of protecting these
civilian population and of ensuring the
provision of humanitarian assistance is
a cessation of hostilities we will never
let up in insisting on the need to seek
out paths for dialogue and diplomacy
which might lead us to putting an end to
this war thank you Mr President
I think the representative of Mexico for
their statement I'll now give the floor
to the representative of France
for their briefings
after launching it's a war of aggression
has crossed a new threshold it is
indiscriminately pounding and has been
for 10 days the towns of Ukraine and it
deliberately chose to strike civilian
infrastructure and particular energy
infrastructure in Kiev in Sumi in nepro
is not even trying to hide the crimes
it's committing Russia is violating the
founding principles of the United
Nations and the norms and standards that
stem from it namely planning aggression
peaceful settlement of disputes
sovereignty of states and the respect
for territorial Integrity
the United Nations General Assembly
unequivocally
and overwhelmingly condemned these
attacks
by targeting civilians
is deliberately violating International
humanitarian law it is something trying
to break the morale of the Ukrainian
Nation by indiscriminately striking
against the Ukrainian towns and cities
Russia wants to terrorize by destroying
essential civilian infrastructure in
particular in the energy
pressure intends to lead to energy and
heating shortfalls as the winter is
approaching it is counting on the
suffering of the civilians including
women children and the elderly
Ukraine stands
has mobilized the means to help Ukraine
this winter
Mr President we urge Russia to comply
with International humanitarian law and
to Allah the access for humanitarians to
civilian and populations who are in
these territories which it claims to
have occupied as well as two prisoners
of War including those which are
detained in Russia we are particularly
worried about them their atrocities and
the destruction which result from the
this aggression could constitute our
crimes and their perpetrators have to be
held accountable on the 22nd of
September last in this Council Minister
of Foreign Affairs miss Catherine
Colonel stated that there would be no
impunity for the criminals the
international criminal court has to move
forward swiftly in its work by going up
as high as possible up the um chain of
responsibility France supports together
with many partners a collection of
evidence through inquiry mechanisms as
well as National and international
jurisdictions Mr President it is
now been solidly document energy that
the Russian Armed Forces use Iranian
drones in Ukraine
notably two indiscriminately bomb
civilian infrastructure the provision of
this equipment by Iran Russia is a
violation of resolution 2231 as we
stated together with our partners from
Germany and UK in the letters sent today
to members of the council the European
Union yesterday
adopted new sanctions against Iranian
entities and individuals implicated in
the production and transfer of the
drones
France supports the appeal by Ukraine to
the Secretariat to investigate and
report to the members of this Council in
line with its mandate
demands that Iran immediately sees any
in all form of support to the warm of
aggression launched by Russia against
Ukraine it demands that Russia and Iran
sees violating resolution 2231 France
condemns from the more the complicity of
Belarus whose territory continues being
used for missile or drone strikes
against Ukraine and finally Mr President
the general assembly vote last week was
Final
Russia is alone and massively condemned
by International Community
is strengthened by International
solidarity we will continue
supporting the Ukrainian people for as
long as is necessary all of the
humanitarian economic and Military
Support that they will need um will be
provided to them to exercise their right
of legitimate defense and Safeguard
their freedom I thank you I think the
representative of France for a statement
I now give the floor to the
representative of Kenya
thank you Mr President
I thank and Secretary General Rosemary
decalo and Miss Denise Brown for their
briefings
it is regrettable Mr President that
rather than a resort to dialogue and
diplomacy to end this conflict
we are seeing an escalation of military
activity
the sustained targeting of civilians and
objects indispensable to survival of the
civilian population
including residential homes
Health Facilities
shelters as well as Power and Water
infrastructure is a violation of
international law and international
humanitarian law
civilians continue to Bear the brunt of
the conflict in urban areas as witnessed
in cave and cities in east and south of
Ukraine
we convey our condolences to the brief
families and wish a quick recovery to
all the victims
also alarming are the persistent threats
being made of the use of weapons of mass
destruction
we continue to urge for the protection
of all nuclear installations including
the separation Nuclear Power Plant
the continued intensification of
conflict will only further undermine the
prospects of a longer term negotiated
peace settlement
it could also give way to the
strengthening of armed alliances in
preparation for a protracted war that
could cause State fragility among
currently stable economies in Europe and
Beyond
Kenya therefore continues to call for an
immediate cessation of hostilities
to allow for dialogue for a long-term
solution
in the meantime
Kenya especially thanks the U.N bodies
and agencies
as well as other institutions and
governments
for their steadfast efforts to alleviate
suffering in every possible way
we continue to call for these U.N
agencies
to be granted and hindered humanitarian
access to those in need
Mr President
in already put insecure regions
especially in Africa due to extreme
weather conditions and conflict the war
in Ukraine has worsened the situation
it has disrupted Global food supply
chains
creating shortages and sharp increases
in prices
the Black Sea grain initiative and the
agreement to ensure an impeded exports
of Russian food and fertilizer to World
Markets what what a promising start and
we continue to advocate for its
maintenance
we also urge that any efforts to deploy
emergency food and energy security
mechanisms in industrialized countries
be accompanied by efforts to transform
Food Systems in food insecure regions a
major part of this endeavor
would be making the necessary
Investments to ensure that Africa is
food self-sufficient
Mr President
the last two world was
came as a surprise
we do not want this war in Ukraine to be
remembered as the beginning of a third
world war
all for it to lead to the fracturing of
the global governance system
it is I time that all states directly
and indirectly involved in this conflict
to open channels of communication
they should use they should use them to
explore the conditions that can lead to
Association of hostilities followed by a
negotiation that addresses the war in
Ukraine and stabilizes the European
security order
it is also time for states with
influence rich and vision for a stable
Global Order to begin a conversation on
the next steps to advance a worldwide
demand for a dialogue regarding Ukraine
and other major security flash points
it is also time
for Security Council reform efforts to
accelerate
without reform to permanent membership
the present format will lose its
relevance and be overtaken by competing
multilateral Arrangements
Kenya Rate rates once again is respect
for the sovereignty territorial
integrity and political independence of
Ukraine I thank you
I thank the representative of Kenya for
that statement and I'll give the floor
to the representative of China
Mr Preston
period has witnessed continued
intensification of the country
underground in Ukraine the constantly
deteriorating humanitarian situation and
the other Bleaker prospects for peace
which China finds most concerning the
crisis
developing countries under tremendous
stress and exposed global economic
development to severe shocks
and work tirelessly together to promote
the ask de-escalation and cooling down
of the situation and the early
realizations of ceasefire and secession
of hostilities today I wish to emphasize
the following three imperatives
to effectively comply with International
humanitarian laws
is a code of conduct and parties in a
complex situation must walk abide by
civilians and civilians facilities
should be fully protected and all
parties should facilitate the evacuation
of people and the provisions of
humanitarian relief nuclear power plants
energy pipelines Bridges and other
critical infrastructure of great
importance to public safety and social
stability and should not be the target
of military attacks all parties involved
should exercise maximum restraint avoid
words and actions that exacerbate
confrontation and cause miscalculation
and prevent a conflict from further
escalating and expanding and from
sliding to a more dangerous dangerous
Brink second to step up continuously
humanitarian assistance nearly eight
months of intense conflict have led to a
severe shortage of supplies in many
places in the basic public services such
as water electricity Heating and Medical
Care are difficult to secure secure as
winter approaches millions of people
especially women showing and other
vulnerable groups need to rely on
crimination Aid to Echo the living China
appreciates the effort of international
human agencies and the Ukraine's
neighboring countries to mitigate the
humanitarian crisis
International Community to continue to
provide assist to Ukraine under the
principles of humanity neutrality
impartiality and Independence and to
continue to help its neighboring
countries the shared pressure in order
to ensure the proper resettlement
evolved in conflict-affected people
to make every effort to contain the
spirit of the effects in the era of
globalization the implementation was all
around indiscriminate sanctions but only
accelerate the transmission of the
crisis push-up International commodity
prices destabilize the global industrial
and supply chain and leave all countries
in the world not pleased with developing
countries exposed to the daliters impact
the International Community should get
United and work together to maintain the
uninterrupted operation of Global Food
energy in the financial markets and
remove political obstacles to
International economic and trade-off
cooperation maintaining and expanding
the return of Ukrainian and Russian food
and fertilizers to the international
market is important for stabilizing
Global Foods prices and secure in the
supply of Agriculture
China's supports the continued effective
implementation of the Black Sea Green
initiative and at the memorandum and the
export of Russian food and his
fertilizers Mr President
peace is the fundamental solution to the
human determined crisis in Ukraine and
the only way to achieve long-term peace
and stability in Ukraine and the
regional at large no matter how great
difficulties are the door to a political
settlement cannot be closed the process
of diplomatic negotiations cannot be
stored and efforts to stop the war and
the promote talks cannot be slackened
the facts about the past eight months
have proven that sanctions in pressure
block confrontation and political
isolation are not in fact ways to
resolve the crisis the International
Community should focus on encouraging
peace twice and seeking a political
Solution by persuading the parties to
resume peace talks and stop fighting at
an early date
in an effort to achieve the soonest a
peaceful solution to the crisis
China's position and the Ukraine issue
is as clear as it is consistent we
empathize with the Ukrainian people for
their pride China has put forward a
six-point initiative and humanitarian
situation in Ukraine and an
International Food security cooperation
initiative and has provided batches of
the emergency human determine assistance
to Ukraine
a responsible country China will
continue to play a construct role in
promoting peace talks and to continue to
make positive contributions to
alleviating the humanitarian crisis
thank you Mr President
I thank the representative of China for
that statement I now give the floor to
the representative of India
thank you Mr President
let me Begin by thanking USG Rosemarie
De Carlo
and U.N resident and humanitarian
coordinator in Ukraine Ms Dennis Brown
for their respective briefings on the
situation in Ukraine with regard to the
protection of civilians and the
humanitarian situation
India continues to remain concerned over
the situation in Ukraine
the conflict has resulted in loss of
lives and countless miseries for its
peoples particularly for women children
and elderly
with Millions becoming homeless and
forced to take shelter in neighboring
countries
reports of attacks on civilians and
civilian infrastructure in the recent
weeks is deeply worrying
we reiterate our grave concern in this
regard
International principles and
jurisprudence West responsibility on
parties to the conflict to ensure that
civilians and civilian infrastructure
are not targeted in situations of armed
conflict
civilians in conflict-affected areas
need safe and endured and Rapid access
to basic Services often provided by
humanitarian workers
as we have been retreating in this
Council all humanitarian Aid and
assistance must be primarily Guided by
the universal principles of humanity
neutrality impartiality and Independence
these measures must not be politicized
Mr President
since the beginning of the conflict in
Ukraine India has consistently called
for immediate cessation of hostilities
and an end to the violence
India has called upon both sides to
return to the path of diplomacy and
dialogue and also expressed its support
for all diplomatic efforts to end the
conflict
we believe that no solution can be
arrived at the cost of innocent lives
our prime minister has spoken to the
Presidents of Ukraine and Russia on
multiple locations and retreated India's
position
India stands ready to support all such
efforts aimed at de-escalation
the impact of Ukraine conflict is not
just limited to Europe
the conflict is exacerbating concerns
over food fertilizer and fuel security
particularly in the developing countries
it is necessary for all of us to
adequately appreciate the importance of
equity affordability and accessibility
on these critical issues for the global
South
open markets must not become an argument
to perpetuate inequity and promote
discrimination
in this context we hope that the grain
deal agreed in June will be implemented
by all parties earnestly
however we believe this alone may not be
sufficient to address the food security
concerns
Mr President India's approach to the
Ukraine conflict will continue to be
people-centric
on our part we are providing both
humanitarian assistance to Ukraine and
economic support to some of our
neighbors in the global South under
economic distress even as they stare at
the escalating costs of food or fuel and
of fertilizers which has been a
consequential Fallout of the ongoing
conflict
we hope that the International Community
will continue to respond positively to
the calls for humanitarian assistance we
support calls urging for guarantees of
safe passage to deliver essential
humanitarian and medical supplies
India so far dispatched 12 Consignments
of humanitarian Aid to Ukraine and
stands ready to do more
in conclusion Mr President
let me reiterate that the global order
is anchored in the principles of the U.N
Charter international law and respect
for sovereignty and territorial
Integrity of all states I thank you
representative of India for his
statement and now give the floor to the
representative of the United Arab
Emirates
Mr President
I'd like to begin by thanking under
Secretary General Rosemary DeCarlo
and Resident coordinator Denise Brown
for their briefings
as we heard today a significant
percentage of critical civilian
infrastructure including power stations
and water supply infrastructure has
either been damaged or destroyed
in just one week a third of Ukraine's
power stations are reported to have been
knocked off the electricity Grid at a
critical time leaving people without gas
for cooking and heating with winter
approaching
as the war continues ukrainians needs
for humanitarian Aid are compounded
further
the International Community must step up
its support to alleviate the suffering
of civilians and ensure that their basic
needs are covered
to this end the UAE announced 100
million U.S dollars in humanitarian Aid
to Ukraine earlier this week
however other parts of the world cannot
be neglected we must ensure that those
most in need globally do not become an
afterthought
access remains a major hurdle for
humanitarian organizations particularly
in the areas witnessing the most intense
fighting in eastern Ukraine
those unable to escape the fighting such
as people with disabilities the elderly
and the sick have become vulnerable to
shifting battle lines
we commend the efforts of humanitarian
organizations in this context and urge
cooperation by the parties to resolve
all impediments to access
we once again reiterate our call on
parties to abide by their obligations
under international law including
International humanitarian law to ensure
the protection of civilians and civilian
infrastructure including energy
infrastructure
civilian objects must never be a target
of attack
Mr President despite the deeply
concerning developments in the conflict
we have seen some movement between the
parties that has led to tangible
positive outcomes on concrete issues
while momentum towards broader
negotiations is still lacking prisoner
exchanges including the exchange
announced earlier this week show the
potential for positive outcomes
the agreements to facilitate the export
of food and fertilizers were significant
and positive steps that contributed to a
decline in the index for Global food
prices
nevertheless the full implementation
expansion and extension of the
agreements remains critical to address
Global Food insecurity
compromise diplomacy and dialogue Remain
the only way forward to prevent further
suffering
we commend the United Nations and others
who have worked to facilitate
constructive engagement between the
parties
Mr President the world wants peace in
Ukraine a piece that is sustainable and
in accordance with the UN Charter and
international law
there is no alternative to a cessation
of hostilities throughout Ukraine and a
peaceful resolution to the conflict
thank you Mr President
I thank the representative of the United
Arab Emirates for his statement I now
give the flaw to the representative of
Brazil thank you
Mr President let me start by thanking
both our reefers for their informative
interventions
I'll make two comments on the subject
first Brazil regrets that after nearly
eight months of conflict in Ukraine the
civilian population continues to suffer
there is no justification for attacks
perpetrated on civilian targets such as
those recorded in Kiev and other major
Ukrainian cities in the last few days
the damage to the energy sector which
according to reports by our Embassy in
Kiev has reached 30 percent of its
generating capacity is particularly
worrisome
the rigors of the coming winter will add
to the humanitarian crisis to continue
reports of Civilian casualties and
attacks against civilian infrastructure
attest to the urgency of opening
channels of humanitarian dialogue
between the parties
Brazil recalls the obligations of all
states under international law and of
all parties and international
humanitarian law
missile launches and drone strikes must
be halted
an impeded access to humanitarian
assistance to those in need should be
guaranteed by all parties
my second point
we believe it's important to discuss our
Collective response to the conflict
in our discussions with other
delegations we note increased
frustration with what is perceived as
insufficient efforts by the council to
facilitate a peaceful solution
many are disappointed with the fact that
divisions have prevailed over what is
expected from us
the willingness to engage in dialogue
Mr President the U.N Charter outlawed
War as a legitimate means of resolving
conflicts
reaffirming this principle is essential
but not sufficient in light of our
Collective responsibilities
this Council should actively contribute
to all possible efforts towards the
ceasefire and to negotiations between
the parties
different ideas have been circulated
by other delegations to facilitate
direct talks between the parties the
council should explore them Brazil is
willing to engage in these efforts and
invites other members to consider new
pets in order to abbreviate the
suffering of the Ukrainian people and I
thank you
I thank the representative of Brazil for
his statement I now give the floor to
the representative of the United States
thank you Mr President and thank you to
under Secretary General DeCarlo and
humanitarian coordinator Brown for your
briefings
colleagues Russia has shown again and
again that it disregards the U.N Charter
and international law
we are in this chamber today because of
the mounting consequences and human toll
of Russia's unprovoked and unlawful
invasion of its neighbor and fellow U.N
member state
as we just heard there are 7.7 million
ukrainians living as refugees and over 6
million more displaced in Ukraine
that is nearly one-third of the
population that cannot go home
nearly half the population needs
humanitarian assistance
and as Miss Brown explained needs will
exacerbate in the winter
and as needs increase Russia's forces
hit civilian infrastructure and
humanitarian convoys with renewed
relentlessness
undermining the civilian population's
ability to survive cold winter
temperatures
this includes a massive barrage against
Ukraine cities on October 10. which the
Secretary General called quote another
unacceptable escalation close quote of
the war
as insecurity broken supply chains and
mass displacement hamper health care
across Ukraine
a U.N partner reports some 500 attacks
by Russ's forces on Health Care
Personnel facilities and transportation
between February 24 and September 7.
as humanitarian organizations scale up
efforts to reach recently retaken areas
Russia's retaliatory strikes and the
prevalence of landmines posts safety
risks to humanitarian personnel and
other civilians
the U.N estimates 4.3 billion will be
needed to provide ukrainians with
humanitarian Aid
since February the United States has
provided over 1.5 billion in assistance
to this end
we urge countries to help the UN meet
these goals as we continue to stand
firmly behind Ukrainian people
from the beginning of its full-scale
invasia Russian has shown contempt for
this Council
this continues with evidence that since
August and in violation of the U.N
security Council resolution 2231
Iran has transferred mohajair and Shahid
series uavs to Russia these Iranian
origin uavs have been subsequently used
in multiple attacks against Ukraine
including the massive barrage on October
10 which hit civilians and civilian
infrastructure
in addition to the easily identifiable
remnants of these uavs recovered in
Ukraine there is significant publicly
available documentation including
photographs and video of these uavs
being used against Ukraine
the UN must investigate any violations
of U.N security Council resolutions
and we must not allow Russia or others
to impede or threaten the U.N from
carrying out its mandated
responsibilities
we take this opportunity to refute
resolutely Russia's false assertion that
Geneva conventions do not apply to
captured foreign
volunteers Russia's obligations as a
party to the Geneva conventions and
their first additional protocol apply to
its detention and treatment of any
individuals in the armed conflict
members of Ukraine's Armed Forces
including Third Country National
volunteers must be treated as prisoners
of War under the Geneva conventions and
afforded the treatment and protections
commensurate with that status
finally we cannot forget the spillover
effects of this war which have
exacerbated Global Food insecurity
we must continue to Champion the efforts
of and work to renew the Black Sea grain
initiative
under this initiative more than 300
ships with over 7 million metric tons of
grain and other food have left Ukraine's
ports
as the U.N has pointed out the
initiative helps calm markets and limit
food price inflation
in fact the U.N food and agricultural's
food price index has fallen since its
Spike at the start of the war and wheat
prices are back at pre-war levels
we cannot tolerate any backsliding at
the expense of the world's hungry
in conclusion Mr Mr President let me say
to the countries on this Council that
over the many months since the
escalation of this conflict have never
mentioned Russia I would say this
if women matter urge Russia to silence
its guns if children matter ask Russia
to withdraw its forces
if the U.N Charter matters call on
Russia to respect Ukraine's sovereignty
territorial integrity and political
Independence they calls for diplomacy
only enable Russia as it commits further
abuses
we in this chamber charged with the
protection of Global Peace and security
must continue to call for accountability
and Russia's immediate cessation of its
illegal war of aggression against
Ukraine thank you Mr President
I thank the representative of the United
States for his statement I now give the
flaw to the representative of Ireland
thank you president I also want to thank
honor Secretary General di Carlo and
Miss Brown for your briefings
Mr President we meet at the end of
another critical week for Ukraine and
its people
they struggle daily with massive
disruption to vital Power and Water
Supplies the result of continued attacks
by the Russian Federation on Ukraine's
critical civilian infrastructure
direct attacks on hospitals and
Healthcare facilities places of care and
refuge
many are now only personally functional
or reliant on limited backup power
Russian attacks have also hated
residential buildings killing civilians
as they sleep
the people of Ukraine are paying the
ultimate price for a senseless War not
of their choosing
while the world has called for peace the
Russian Federation has instead chosen
the part of escalation in this war
across Ukraine we have seen explosive
weapons including prohibited cluster
Munitions being used in populated areas
and against civilian infrastructure
landmines jeopardizing civilians
agricultural production food security
and safe humanitarian access
Ireland is concerned by the use of
Iranian supplied unmanned aerial
vehicles that bring debt destruction and
horror to The Straits of cave and
elsewhere
their acquisition by Russia would
contravene Security Council resolution
2231.
these attacks on civilian targets appear
to have just one goal in mind to
intimidate and terrorize the civilian
population
they represent a blatant disregard for
human life they constitute a serious
violation of international law and they
are simply unconscionable
we once again call on the Russian
Federation to comply with its
obligations under international law
including International and humanitarian
law
we urge the Russian Federation to
refrain from further escalation to take
all feasible measures to prevent
civilian casualties and damage to
civilian infrastructure and to
facilitate life-saving humanitarian
access without delay
we have just heard how critical this is
as Windsor approaches with the most
vulnerable and Ukrainian society and
turning displaced persons women children
and the elderly facing a particularly
precarious future
Mr President the people of Ukraine have
shown remarkable resolve and
determination in the face of such brutal
adversity
Ireland stands with them today as always
for our part we are determined that the
Russian Federation will be held to
account for its heinous actions There
Are Rules even in war
and when those rules are broken there
must be accountability
accountability for the targeting of
civilians for arbitrary detention human
trafficking and conflict-related sexual
violence
in all situations where International
crimes may have been committed we must
ensure that timely credible
investigations are undertaken that
evidence is rigorously documented under
Witnesses victims and survivors are
supported
last week the general assembly delivered
a clear message of support for Ukraine's
sovereignty and territorial integrity
this was not just about Ukraine but
about protecting the principles and
Shrine in the U.N Charter the very basis
for our rules-based International order
through that same Charter the members of
these United Nations conferred on this
Council the primary responsibility for
the maintenance of International Peace
and security
for exactly eight months now the Russian
Federation has acted with utter
disregard for this responsibility
it continues to bring wanton death and
destruction to Ukraine through its
illegal war of aggression
today I appealed to my fellow members of
this Council to assert our
responsibility for the maintenance of
International Peace and security
to Stand United in calling on the
Russian Federation to end this war and
withdraw from the entire territory of
Ukraine
and to support all efforts of dialogue
and diplomacy to bring about the peace
resolution of this conflict thank you Mr
President
I thank the representative of Ireland
for that statement I now give the floor
to the representative of Ghana thank you
president
I wish to begin my statement by thanking
under Secretary General Rosemary DeCarlo
and Miss Denise Brown the United Nations
resident humanitarian coordinator in
Ukraine for their important but
Sovereign briefings on the humanitarian
situation in Ukraine
now in its eighth month the unjustified
aggression against Ukraine has been
marked by overwhelming suffering death
and destruction
too many people especially the women
children and the elderly continue to
suffer needlessly from the fighting that
has engulfed many cities across Ukraine
the humanitarian statistics as reported
are indeed concerning but can only be
expected to rise should the fighting
continue in the way we are witnessing
it is also important to note the impacts
of the war on pre-existing humanitarian
situations in other parts of the world
where food Aid is largely supplied from
Ukraine
the growing threats of the use of
unconventional weapons and possible
nuclear engagements have been the source
of global uncertainty
Ghana calls for the de-escalation of
tensions the immediate secession of
hostilities and the intensification of
diplomatic efforts to end the war now
rather than later when the cost of
reconciliation and reconstruction would
be unbearable
it is of utmost importance for the
security Council and The Wider
International Community to forge
consensus on concrete measures and
Pathways to stem the rising tensions and
begin a political dialogue for
settlement
we welcome in this regard the continuing
leadership and Pacific role of the
Secretary General and hope that further
gains can be made in the Endeavors for
peaceful settlement
we're grateful to the United Nations
humanitarian agencies and their Partners
who are working under extremely
difficult and dangerous operational
circumstances we pay our respect to all
humanitarian workers who have fallen
while in the service to Mankind in
Ukraine their commitment and sacrifice
to bring relief to the suffering people
must be matched by the international
community's efforts in helping to end
the war
we welcome the humanitarian Aid support
and contributions by some states and
international agencies to see ukrainians
through the winter season
Food Water Shelter warm clothing and
medication would be critical to the
survival of some six and a half million
people internally displaced by the war
we call on both parties to Grant
humanitarian access to all areas where
people require assistance and Edge the
Russian authorities in particular to
Grant and hindered humanitarian access
into the occupied territories
as fighting intensifies we deem it
necessary for the new for new
humanitarian corridors to be created for
the safe passage of civilians to ease
areas to areas of relative safety
we recall the success of the marapol
evacuations and Edge similar
arrangements as a matter of urgency
we condemn all human rights violations
and reiterate our support for
independent transparent and thorough
investigations of such violations
including conflict-related sexual
violence the happenings in Butcher and
eppen must strengthen our resolve to
hold the perpetrators of such acts to
account and avoid impunity
the parties must refrain from targeted
attacks on civilian infrastructure and
other critical infrastructure
apart from imposing severe hardships on
the people the deliberate destruction of
critical energy infrastructure
residential facilities water stations
Healthcare facilities schools and
transport infrastructure constitute
gross violations of international law
and the principles of international
humanitarian law relating to Armed
conflicts in close in Mr President will
reiterate our complete commitment for
the sovereignty political Independence
and territorial Integrity of Ukraine and
remain supportive of international
efforts to alleviate the humanitarian
suffering of the Ukrainian people I
thank you
I thank the representative of Ghana for
her statement I now give the floor to
the representative of the United Kingdom
thank you president
thank you again under Secretary General
De Carlo for your briefing
the thank you resident coordinator Brown
for your invaluable update on the
situation on the ground
and the work the UN team is doing in the
toughest of circumstances
so far this war has killed maimed and
psychologically damaged thousands of
people
Millions have been forced to flee
Ukrainian towns and cities have been
reduced to Rubble
with evidence of atrocities left behind
in the ruins
we have heard unbearable stories of
sexual violence
and the real objectives of the invasion
have been exposed by Russia's attempts
to suppress Ukrainian national identity
and culture and illegally Annex
Ukrainian lands
an act widely condemned by the UN
membership last week
unfortunately
an already appalling situation appears
to be getting worse
under the command of General Sergey
slovkin a man Infamous for brutalities
against civilians in Syria we have seen
A Renewed campaign of drone and missile
strikes across Ukraine
heavily populated areas have been hit
as well as playgrounds
traffic in rush hour
and apartment buildings nowhere near
front lines or military installations
a new wave of bombardment has
deliberately targeted critical National
infrastructure
leaving some 30 percent of Ukraine's
power stations damaged or destroyed
these are attacks on Ukrainian civilians
way of life
and they are a clear breach of
international humanitarian law
they are egregious in their own rights
but even worse as winter approaches
Russian attacks mean that ukrainians are
losing their ability to heat their homes
and cook their food
the intent behind these attacks is clear
Russia is seeking to subjugate Ukraine
by terrorizing civilians
and this is doing so using Weaponry
obtained for Iran in violation of
Security Council resolution 22 31.
now Russia's been trying to distance
distract us with attacks on the un's
Integrity its mandate to investigate
but resolution 2231 is clear
it asks the Secretary General to report
to the Council on its implementation
and this extensive precedence for site
visits to consider evidence
of course the key issue is that wherever
these drones come from
their use against civilians is barbaric
president
Russia's actions are illegal and immoral
and they must come to an end
so once again we call on Russia to stop
its disinformation and misdirection and
its accusations that the West is somehow
responsible for its own atrocities
we call on Russia to heed the calls of
the International Community
respect its obligations under
international law
and stop attacks on civilians energy
infrastructure hospitals and health
facilities
and we call on Russia yet again to end
this war
and return to the path of dialogue
it abandoned in February
finally president
we recognize as others have
The Wider negative impacts of Russia's
War
the positive impact of the Black Sea
grain initiative on global grain prices
is clear and we've heard more about that
today
so we welcome and encourage efforts by
the Secretary General to ensure the
continuation of the agreements
you have the UK's full support
thank you
I thank the representative of the United
Kingdom for his statement I now give the
floor to the representative of Norway
thank you president
let me first thank the briefers for
their candid words to the council today
their accounts leave no doubt about the
devastation this war has brought upon
the people of Ukraine
Norway will continue to stand with
Ukraine and the Ukrainian people against
this Russian aggression which is a gross
violation of international law and the
U.N Charter
we are alarmed by the escalation and
brutality of the recent Russian attacks
on civilians and civilian infrastructure
with missiles and drones
these attacks which seems to deliberate
have killed civilians and hit several
Power facilities across Ukraine
damage to energy infrastructure brings
great humanitarian harm and will
certainly cause illness and death when
the cold winter arrives
these attacks have no military purpose
the aim seemed to be to terrorize the
population
they are illegal and may constitute war
crimes those reps responsible must be
personally held to account
Russia's devastating attacks against
cities and urban areas over the last
eight months have killed and maimed
civilians including children and led to
massive displacement both internally and
across bowlers
we are concerned about sexual and
gender-based violence and human
trafficking that women and unaccompanied
children are particularly exposed to
we must facilitate their return the
delivery of essential services and
mitigate the long-term effects that
Russia's War has imposed on them
president the independent International
Commission of inquiry has concluded that
violation of Human Rights and
international humanitarian law amounting
to war crimes have been committed by
Russian Armed Forces
the killing of civilians Musgraves rape
and other forms of sexual violence
forced disappearance and torture have
all been recorded
along with reports of deportation to
Russia an adjustment to procedures to
allow Russians to adopt Ukrainian
children without the consent of their
parents
and more
the victims deserve justice survivors
must be cared for and those responsible
must be held accountable
but to stop this grotesque violation in
the first place this war must come to an
end Russia must be Droid Stroop from
within the internationally recognized
border of Ukraine and stop the war
president Norway also remained concerned
by the money and accounted for prisoners
of war and others who are missing
because of this conflict
we call on the parties at all levels to
comply with their obligation under
International humanitarian law
this includes support for the
international Committee of the Red Cross
in fulfilling their unique mandate as
laid out in the Geneva conventions
including visiting prisoners of War
president recommend the international
and National humanitarian responders for
their bravery in delivering humanitarian
protection and assistance to those in
need it is critical that humanitarian
actors have full safe and unhindered
access to all those in need we are
particularly concerned about the
situation for the elderly this disabled
and children in Conflict affected areas
president while this war is Raging the
world is facing a food crisis
continuation of the Black Sea grain
initiative is vital and we appreciate
the tireless effort of the Secretary
General
in times of War we need this speaking of
Hope thank you
I thank the representative of Norway for
her statement and I'll give the floor to
the representative of the Russian
Federation
Mr President
the very beginning
other than extending the time of the
meeting today is
including in our list of the
representative of Slovakia Poland
Germany and Greece but we do not have it
it's not a debate that we're having
today but a briefing and the position of
those countries is very well known to us
anyway and they could very well be said
that it could very well be summed up by
the representative of the EU it's
nothing by the desire to show their
faces and international TV screams and
future Mr President we would like you to
be more careful when compiling the list
of those who will be speaking on such uh
at such meetings Mr President we know
the briefing provided by The Intercept
secretary
um in general Rosemary De Carlo and the
resident humanitarian coordinator in
Ukraine Mr Nice Brown president
coordinator in Ukraine Mr Denise Brown
we can see that the U.N Secretariat has
finally become concerned with the topic
of the civilian infrastructure
destruction unfortunately once again
this is a one-sided picture we didn't
hear a word about the destruction that
Kiev has been for eight years inflicting
and continues inflicting in donbass nor
has we heard anything about the victims
amongst the civilians from the Ukrainian
Armed Forces there was no reaction
whatsoever by the secretary to the
horrendous acts of Terror by KF against
such civilian infrastructure as a bridge
in Crimea their shellings all of these
approachia NPP and the kahovska power
plant
[Applause]
the need for the meeting today our
Western colleagues explained by the
intensification of strikes against
Ukrainian infrastructure and civilian
objects by the Russian side all right
let's take a look at what the situation
is actually like in the past two months
the Ukrainian regime and its Western
backers
probably were euphoric because of
tactical movement of Ukrainian forces in
some areas which was arrived at as a
result of an astronomical losses in
personnel and Equipment have been
rehashing the idea that Russia
supposedly exhausted his material and
people's resources and is just about to
start losing on the battlefield
parallel to that the Ukrainian
strategies with a backing for the
Western Masters have for a long time be
using the terrorist methods of sabotage
on the Russian territory there are many
examples of that by the peak of that was
a Act of Terror on the Crimean bridge on
the 8th of October conducted by
Ukrainian Special Forces four people
died partially the road was destroyed of
the road which ensures supplies to the
peninsula foodstuffs medicines and
either vital necessities
the Ukrainian officials including the
Deputy Prime Minister the head of the
ministry on digital transformation of
Ukraine Mikhail fodorov and the
ministerial adviser girashanko openly
savored this crime they were ecstatic
announcements about that made on the
official account of the ministry of
Defense of Ukraine and even though Kiev
was probably reigned in by the Western
Masters very quickly and traditionally
tried to shift the blame on Russia
[Music]
in an internet video confirmed that what
is behind the attacks against the
Crimean bridge and Belgrade oblast is
here here are his words which became
available to millions of Internet users
I quote if you ask me who blew up in
Crimea and Belgrade well the privately I
will tell you then yes it's uh it's us
after an eight years experience in
donbas we know very well what the key of
regime is capable of but we therefore
decided to dampen the further of
overreaching terrorism High Precision
missile strikes and Russian drones hit a
large number of military targets
including the objects of infrastructure
which undermine the military possibility
and the potential of the anti-people of
the landscape regime of course this did
not sit well with West and they became
hysterical and we this is what we're
witnessing loudly and clearly today at
the meeting obviously as was the case
earlier they do not want to face facts
and acknowledge that the civilian
objects were only hit in those cases
when the drones were targeted right next
to the car Target by a Ukrainian
territorial defense and therefore had to
change their course or when the civilian
objects were hit by Ukrainian air
defense who couldn't intercept their
targets there are plenty of cases like
that if they exist on video anyone wants
to look them up
Ukraine today and its Western backers
are trying to um
publicize yet another fake about the
alleged supplies into Russia of
Ukrainian drones in violation of
resolution 2231 31 reject any attempts
to involved into this dirty undertaking
the U.S Secretariat an example of that
is the letter disseminated today the
letter from Germany France and UK which
basically appeals to the secretary to
violate its article 100 of the charter
and the Mandate they have in the
presidential security Council president
note as
2016-44 of January 2016. the United
States went further and in their letter
demanded that the Secretariat command an
investigation which the secretary has no
authority to do this is an outrageous
situation and we have provided our legal
views in an open letter which we
disseminated prior to this meeting today
and we expect that the secretary will
provide us with a definitive
confirmation that they will not
um intend to follow the instructions
from Western countries in violation of
the charter and will not conduct conduct
any investigation if Experts of the UN
to please Western Capital nonetheless
start conducting a pseudo investigation
baselessly referring it to resolution
2231 we can reconsider the entire
package of our relationship with the U.N
secretary because in this case it will
not be possible to call it an impartial
distinguished colleagues they show in
the security Council today is a smoke
screen for the key of regime and its
Bankers the West is trying to uh paint
the key of regime as an innocent victim
of Russian aggression which needs
constant military assistance last week
announces were made about new supplies
to Cave of military goods United States
and the European Union decided to choose
those systems specifically which show
themselves to be most lethal against the
people of donbass and the liberated
territories the United States will give
Kiev yet another portion of hymers
equipment and the high Precision
missiles M31 GM RS and the aviation
anti-radar missiles agm-88 harm Paris
will give
um yet another portion of self
propelled artillery Caesar with 155
millimeter caliber 100 55 millimeter
ammunition to Kiev is announced by
Germany and the leadership of this
country explained to their own people
that this is to help the zelensky regime
in protecting Ukraine well let's take a
look why how they're actually being used
according to DNR at lnr only uh on their
territory from February to October the
Ukrainian shelling is a heavy Weaponry
resulted in damage to more than 10 000
buildings and more than 2 000 civilian
infrastructure entities this includes
424 education facilities in 109 medical
facilities American hymers were actively
used for this shelling
the French Caesars also showed how
powerful they were when fighting
residential buildings schools and other
civilian objects
as a result of French Armament supplies
since June
um internet and no less than five people
died 10 were injured 64 buildings
destroyed the Ukrainian armed forces are
only striking again in into Russian
terrorists territory targeting uh
civilians and civilian infrastructure on
the 10th of October of Belgrade oblis uh
was shelled by more than 100 missiles
including the infamous with a cluster
Warhead a woman died for building
damaged in the village of jetkin in
corsk which has been shelled since the
spring despite the fact that there are
no military objects there two people
were injured on the 13th of October the
ukrainians showed a large Residential
Building in Belcourt a village The
Village Crossing was shot at Customs
Post in near shebeken and other civilian
entities just now on the eve of the
meeting
Ukrainian Armed Forces destroyed
destroyed Industrial Enterprises in that
District I would like to recall that
earlier in this region as well as in
Donuts Ukrainian Armed Forces actively
and indiscriminately use remote mining
systems against civilians including the
leper stock mines The Petal mines on the
16th of October residential buildings in
Newcastle the international airport in
Belgrade two civilians were injured on
the 18th of October the Ukrainian
military had once again
Village on the same day they attacked
six towns in a course called one woman
was hurt a number of buildings and a
number of electricity supply lines prior
to that Ukrainian saboteurs have tried
on several occasions to come commit an
act of sabotage against the course NPP
since October through indiscriminate
artillery shelling using the American
missiles harm more than 30 peaceful
townships in Belgard and and Belgrade
itself
at the same time Kiev encouraged by the
Western patrons is openly boasting about
that is it possible that Kiev and those
who are covering up these things think
that we will acquest to that using their
permission to commit any crime the
permission given by their Western
backers the zelensky regime is
consistently striking civilian
infrastructure on in it on its own
former territory the Ukrainian Armed
Forces for five months have been
shelling the town of novakovka in the
Heritage
up to 120 um missiles strike in a day
most of them American hymers and the
ukrainians target them specifically Dam
so as to break it which will result in
the raising of the water level and this
will flood the adjacent territories
this could result in the death of
thousands of civilians and thousands of
buildings will be damaged we
disseminated today the security Council
our letter calling upon on the U.N
leadership to prevent this horrendous
provocation
Reckless attacks of the Ukrainian Armed
Forces against the zabroska NPP
continues and this creates the dangers
of two nuclear safety the number of
victims civilian victims if the NPP is
seriously damaged not to mention what
will happen when there's a fully fledged
accident with a leak is of no concern to
Kiev they are prepared for any human
victims to make sure that NATO can
continue its proxy war with Russia and
continue supplying Ukraine's with
armaments we continuously inform you and
Leadership about these outrageous
incidents but haven't heard anything
intelligible by way of reaction from it
so far the Ukrainian Fighters managed to
seriously damage the kahovsky and
antonovsky bridges against it
they were used by the citizens of
Harrison to receive Food medicines Etc
another attempt to destroy the antonovic
was a bridge was undertaken on the 19th
of October the Russian air defense
systems managed to protect the bridge
for these attacks once again the
American hymers systems were used the
Ukrainian Fighters also used hymers
earlier so as to strike against the
Detention Facility for azov in Yellen
another horrendous illustration of how
the key of authorities treat the
peaceful people is the executions of
their own Nationals who decided to opt
for Russia on the 20th of September the
ukrainians executed an automobile Convoy
um in new Coupe they were leaving
Ukraine towards Russia about 30 people
died on the 30th of September once again
the refugees who were leaving for the
liberated territories in zapproaches
were hit 30 people died 88 people were
injured yesterday on the 20th of October
the Ukrainian Armed Forces shelled a
ferry which was used to evacuate
civilians who were seeking and trying to
save themselves from shells as a result
of that they are wounded and and killed
including journalism people
on the 4th of October there was an open
appeal from a military personnel of the
25th storm Brigade of the Ukrainian
Armed Force in it they said that they
received a criminal order to totally
eliminate the peaceful um population in
the heart of hopeless the minister of
interior of interior Ukraine um you made
a statement that they would start to
eliminate the enemies of Ukraine as a
result in in the ark of oblast as a pre
per day they detain up to 40 so-called
collaborators what happens to them
thereafter we saw in a video on the 9th
of October where a member of the four of
the azov unit Maxim Jordan talks about
it shows that the bodies of the executed
civilians are being thrown into a ditch
Jordan himself said that they these are
the citizens of kupansk and commented I
quote saying the punishment will come
the metadata of this video showed that
there was recorded
um slightly uh more than 30 minutes
before the publication the bodies are
wearing warm clothes
which is in line with October the
Russian forces have been uh absent from
Copans since September and this shows
that these people have been executed by
Ukrainian neonatists as part of their
cleansing of the city have we heard of
one word uh with um condemnation of this
from Western delegations and your
silence shows that you're hypocritical
you're not at all worried about the fate
of civilians in Ukraine you prefer to
cover up this criminal regime which uh
counts in its ranks nationalist radicals
and open Nazis help them with his
provocations and spreading is about
Russia and Russian Armed Forces once
again I would like to by the way recall
that this and despite all of the
reminders of ours we have not received a
victim of you a list of Ukrainian
victims in butcher in April this shows
it once again that the cave and
authorities have nothing as evidence to
provide to confirm their accusations our
Western colleagues are trying to say
that there is nothing that needs to be
proven all we need to do is just uh
trust to take the words of the
representative of the cave regime at
face value Mr President before
concluding I'd like to warn in advance
that listening to yet another portion of
spiteful tyrants from the representative
of the Ukrainian regime is a security
Council and thus provide him with very
strange and perverse pleasure that he
gets from that it's not something that I
will do all those who are familiar with
his recent boorish insults against
Russian diplomats and social networks
will know what I'm referring to
regrettably such outbursts reflect the
current state of Ukrainian diplomacy and
show kiev's inability and lack of
Readiness for any kind of dialogue much
less for a civilized one I thank you
I thank the representative of the
Russian Federation for his statement I
now give the floor to the representative
of Albania president
thank you USD Carlo and Resident
coordinator Brown for your information
on the situation in Ukraine
since 24 February this year every of our
meetings on Ukraine has started on a
most sobering way deploring an
unjustified aggression
expressing the concern deep concerns for
the useless loss of life and repeating
unheeded calls for Russia to stop
this one is no different as the
situation has not changed and the next
week will Mark exactly eight months
since the Special Operation since the
special Russian Madness started in
Ukraine
I wish nonetheless
like to pause for a moment get out of
the Grim situation and congratulate
Ukraine and its people for receiving the
sucker of price awarded last week by the
European Parliament praising ukrainians
who are standing up for what we all
believe in
praise defending themselves but fighting
for common values protecting democracy
freedom and rule of law it is as
symbolic as meaningless as meaningful
sorry
Mr President
Ukraine Remains the only place in Europe
where since February sirens sound day
and night
thousands of people have died and have
been injured most of them caused by use
of explosive weapons including shelling
missiles and airstrikes
attacks against civil infrastructure
including damages of residential
buildings schools and hospitals
Healthcare facilities have continued
affecting people's people's access to
critical services
now Russia is escalating it
and is targeting key civilian
infrastructure namely energy
installations but also residential areas
with the clear aim to terrorize
population inflict severe damage and
leave entire families women and children
without water electricity and heating
while winter is approaching this is
another and higher level of Cruelty
moreover it is now being carried out
with the extended malicious hand of Iran
notoriously known for its destabilizing
policies through an open breach of
security Council resolution 20 to 31. we
call on the U.N not to yield to threats
but undertaken an adequate verification
of reports that hundreds of drones used
by Russian forces in Ukraine have been
unlawfully imported from Iran as part of
the regular report of the Secretary
General on the implementation resolution
2231 in accordance with para 7 on note
44. it is there everybody can verify it
after all my question and maybe not only
mine is what Russia has to hide from an
independent impartial investigation a
routine exercise to examine evidence and
that the secret has done plenty of times
didn't they agree for a similar inquiry
from the U.N secret after the bombing of
a prison where more than 50 prisoners
were killed in donbass which Still
Remains unlucidated
Mr President
last March in this chamber I asked Ocha
if they were able to corroborate
allegations of sexual violence used by
Russian soldiers
it was not an accusation but a request
for information and clarity
the Russian delegation reacted stating
that Russian soldiers would never commit
such acts as they have high standards
and rules
guess what now we have un reports
compiled after meticulous investigation
which say that they had documented
patterns of summary executions and
lawful confinement torture ill treatment
rape and other sexual violence committed
in areas occupied by Russian Armed
Forces
such despicable behaviors seem not to
have spared children including allegedly
a four-year-old girl a baby
the commission of inquiry reports that
sometimes family members including
children were forced to witness these
crimes this is simply sickening and
doesn't meet any known standards of
human behavior let alone military
discipline and these are no high
standards these are monstrous activities
crimes war crimes crimes against
humanity and one day they will be
presented before the court
Mr President let me highlight another
worry
weeks after Russia and Belarus announced
the formation of a new Joint Force and
days after the force started to risk to
assemble in Belarus there is reason to
fear a rising military threat from the
north
thousands of Russian servicemen's
equipment and aircrafts are flooding
into Belarus accompanied by increasingly
badly caused rhetoric from Russian and
Belarusian leadership
I would not be surprised to hear that
this has nothing to do with Ukraine that
they are performing drills in their own
countries and so and so on the fact is
that we have been played this before and
as we know now every time there has been
a Russian denial regarding Ukraine the
exact opposite has happened
Mr President last week after the council
was blocked in a pattern we are all
familiar with the unga voted to have
overwhelmingly condemned the latest
Russian annexation of parts of the
territory of Ukraine
the world response was clear and
resounding and Russia was again alone
immut in denial
Albania does not recognize any of the
Russian actions they have no legitimacy
no legal effect they are null and void
and luhansk taneets Kirsten and zapariza
are and will remain Ukrainian
territories this war must end and we
call on Russia to put an end to it by
respecting the sovereignty and
territorial Integrity of Ukraine in its
internationally organized borders I
thank you
I thank the representative of Albania
for that statement I will now make a
decoration in my capacity as a
representative of Gabon I thank under
Secretary General Rosemary decano
um the resident and humanitarian
coordinator Nina's Brown for their
briefings dear colleagues the war in
Ukraine continues it is increasingly
brutal and deadly and the humanitarian
situation is worsening constantly
civilians and civilian infrastructure
continue to be the target of attacks
shelling and this is having grave
repercussions on electricity Supply
water supply and Telecommunications
use of remote weapons adds to the
climate of Terror
I will hear halt my inventory of damage
and distress to say once again that it
is time for this Council to mobilize to
put an end to this wall it is time for
the for our debates our language and our
action to focus on solving the Ukraine
crisis that has been
constant appeal since the very beginning
of the crisis we have spent almost eight
months
counting the death numbers and numbers
of War refugees
during these eight months made each of
our meetings a moment which we heard
insults regarding causes protests
Devastation we've listed
responsibilities talked about the
current imminent and potential
consequences of the conflict
that hasn't in any way serve to mitigate
the scope of Devastation seen on the
grounds today we are still at the stage
of taking inventory of fears of
atrocities and of humanitarian distress
and we're doing that in a one side
against the other time and that leaves
every nation of the world with no option
but to side with either one camp or the
other
dear colleagues it is time to find a
solution which will see the weapons in
Ukraine Falls Island the silencing the
weapons is no doubt the aspiration of
any and all peoples gripped by
insecurity that war brings with it
silencing the guns is first and foremost
the vocation of this organization call
upon the parties to the conflict to
respect International humanitarian law
and the resolutions of this Council
namely resolution
2231 and to allow unfettered
humanitarian access with winter around
the corner we call for a humanitarian
truce and for the opening of new
humanitarian corridors in order to
preserve access to drinking water
electricity heating medical treatment
and to facilitate the distribution of
humanitarian a Aid that the disaster
stricken people are so desperately need
dear colleagues there is a time for
everything a time for antagonism a time
for dialogue and we think that the time
has come to silence the weapons the time
has come to give them dialogue a chance
my country calls upon the parties to
commit to negotiations in good faith to
put an end to this deadly war and to
achieve peaceful coexistence in the
region thank you
well thank you Mr President I'm happy
that months if not years of our efforts
to remove Russia from the security
Council bring fruits and now at least
the Ambassador is removed from the
council
the day will come and Russia will be
removed from the council altogether
Mr President distinguished members of
the security Council
under Secretary General De Carlo
and
Miss Brown resident coordinator
I regret the security Council
is still compelled to listen to this
representative who just fled
and the only thing he has done over
almost eight months
of invasion
is pile lies upon lies
at every meeting
about every aspect of the war of
aggression
his master ordered in February
let me remind you of what this person
said
at the security Council meetings
at the beginning of this invasion
and I will quote very carefully
the Russian military
poses no threat
to Ukraine's peaceful citizens
the military does not fire
at peaceful civilian infrastructure
the flat Ambassador said on the 27th
February
let me give you let me offer rather you
another quote from this person
I quote
we repeat again that the goal of
Russia's special military operation
is not to occupy Ukraine
or to harm the local population
Russia's special operation
does not impact critical civilian
infrastructure
said the Ambassador who just left on the
28th of February in the East very
chamber
I wonder whether Putin's representative
is ready to repeat these statements now
apparently not because he's not
physically present
against the backdrop of mass Graves and
tens of thousands of ukrainians killed
and tortured by Russians
against the backdrop of the attempted
illegal annexation of four Ukrainian
regions by the Russian Federation which
the U.N General Assembly rejected last
Wednesday by an overwhelming majority
and finally against the backdrop of
recent deliberate attacks against
Ukrainian critical energy infrastructure
Mr President in the wake of deliberate
attacks by Russia since the 24th of
February Ukrainian law enforcement
agencies have registered the damage or
destruction of
51
412 civilian infrastructure facilities
since October the 10th there have been
about 300 missile and drone attacks by
Russia targeting energy facilities and
other civilian infrastructure in 14
regions
including the capital city
as a result of these attacks at least 17
civilians have been killed and 99
injured
nearly 40 percent of Ukraine's energy
facilities have been damaged or
destroyed
power plants
central heating plants Transformers
oil storages
distribution devices overhead power
lines and other energy equipment
throughout the country remain under
Russian fire almost on a daily basis
now let me bring you back
to the history of this console
I would like to remind all in this
regard that
on the 13th of February 2017
the security Council adopted resolution
2341
initiated by Ukraine
on the protection of critical
infrastructure against terrorist attacks
the resolution called upon all member
states to ensure
that they have established criminal
responsibility for terrorist attacks
intended to destroy or disable critical
infrastructure as well as the planning
of training for and financing of and
logistical support for such attacks
even Russia joined consensus on that day
even more was recalling
that Russia claimed at that meeting and
I quote again
it is not worthwhile to start
negotiations
that seek merely to outline obvious
points end of quote
obvious for Russia indeed
can the Russian representative state it
again apparently not
for the record that it is obvious that
the destruction and disabling of
critical infrastructure should be
regarded as terrorist attacks that
entail criminal responsibility
every part of the criminal regime in
Moscow
is soaked with blood
and permeated by crime
it is not surprising therefore that
Putin has chosen as a new commander of
his Army in Ukraine
a person
who is Infamous for his both blood
thirsty and criminal nature
in 1991 during the coup d'etat attempt
launched by Soviet hardliners
this person
his name is suraavikin
ordered his military unit
to drive through barricades erected by
pro-democracy protesters
in the streets of Moscow
three of them were killed
and Surah we can spend half a year in a
pre-trial Center on the investigation
seven years later he was convicted
of legal possession and trafficking
of firearms
and given a one-year suspended sentence
as a commander of Russian forces in
Syria sura weekend was responsible for
unconstrained bombing and attacks on
civilian targets including schools and
hospitals
now in an attempt to live up to the
expectations of his masterminds he
transfers the practice of making no
different differentiation between
soldiers and civilians to Ukrainian soil
Mr President we have information that's
Russia
is deliberately
preparing the ground for a large-scale
disaster in the south of Ukraine
Russian terrorists have
mined them and Aggregates of the kahovka
hydroelectric power plant one of the
largest power facilities in Ukraine
the dam of this power plant holds about
18 million cubic meters of water
if Russian terrorists blow up this Dam
more than 80 settlements including her
son
with hundreds of thousands of people
living there will be in an area of Rapid
flooding
the water supply at a large part of the
south of Ukraine may be distorted
these Russian terrorist attack would
could leave the zapparesian nuclear
power plant without water for cooling as
this water is taken from the kahovka
reservoir
the Russian representative may call this
information I quote his own words
speculations and unfounded accusations
triggered I quote him again
I wish to generate Hysteria
we heard these words
from the same person
at the security council meeting on the
31st of January
accusing those who Express concerns of a
Russian military
preparations on Ukrainian borders off I
quote
whipping up Hysteria
and claiming that I quote
discussion about the threat of war is
provocative
and
yes it's proclamative in and off itself
he tried to mooc the information about
planned military action that I quote
is going to take place in just a few
weeks time
we all know what happened
in a few weeks time then
and now it is necessary to act
immediately so that Russia does not have
the chance to commit another Act of
Terror
an international observation mission to
the kahokov caparo plant is needed
it is also necessary to return the
Ukrainian personnel there and ensure
immediate and professional the mining of
the Aggregates and the dam itself
we are concerned over the announced by
the Russian occupiers so-called
evacuation of residents of temporarily
occupied Herson region
the consequences of such an evacuation
may be unpredictable because it is about
forced deportation of citizens of
Ukraine
and every time the Russian fakes and
propaganda have been refuted by credible
and independent sources
we all remember Russian attempts to
avoid responsibility for the butcher
Massacre attempts failed almost
immediately due to the numerous
eyewitness accounts findings and
investigations
the most recent contribution to
revealing the truths about Russian war
crimes and crimes against humanity was
made by the independent International
Commission of inquiry on Ukraine
established by the young Human Rights
Council
Mr President
our memories about convulsions of the
Russian delegation in the general
assembly on Monday October the 10th are
still fresh
we have just witnessed
how the Russian delegation desperately
tries to prevent the U.N from
allegations of gross violations over
Security Council resolution
we are extremely concerned over the use
of long range uavs of Iranian origin by
Russia in his indiscriminate attacks
against civilians and civilian
infrastructure in Ukraine
these represents a blatant violation of
the joint comprehensive plan of action
signed by China France Germany the
United Kingdom the United States the
European Union and Russia itself
and then adopted by the U.N security
Council resolution 2231
as you are aware according to the annex
B to that resolution the prohibitions
were imposed on the supply sale or
transfer to or from Iran
this September the UAV smart has granted
to
were captured by the forces of Defense
of Ukraine and after technical
examination they appear to be similar to
Iranian uavs she had 136.
which are capable of delivering payload
to the range exceeding 300 kilometers
and fully correspond to the technical
parameters set in the document as slash
2015 546.
as you are also aware on October 15 2022
Ukraine officially addressed the U.N
security Council chair on these
violations and requested to start the
relevant investigations
however there is even more wiring
information about strong intentions of
Russia to continue further attacks on
Ukraine with the advanced Iranian
missile and UAV systems including
ballistic missiles fatigue 110 and
zolfah car capable of striking targets
of the range of 300 and 700 kilometers
respectively
this will bring more deaths and
destruction to Ukraine and this will
represent another gross violation of you
you un Security Council resolution 2231.
which calls on Iran not to undertake any
activity related to ballistic missiles
designed to be capable of delivering
nuclear weapons
another important element that has to be
thoroughly examined is related to the
possible expert by Russia to Iran of
dual use services
including technical assistance or
technical information
by providing Iran as original exporter
with the data on the results of uav's
utilization at the battlefield in
Ukraine
Iran also has to face serious
consequences already now for his illegal
actions that help to escalate the
Russian war of aggression against
Ukraine
that is why we call on all states to
consider any possible steps to stop this
kind of uav's missile or conventional
arms transfers from Iran
we fully agree that the UN investigation
should start immediately and we welcome
strong support for such steps by many
members of the un's security Council
we have already invited un experts to
visit Ukraine to inspect recovered
Iranian origin uavs in order to
facilitate implementation of the
security Council resolution 2231.
distinguished colleagues Ukraine remains
committed to the implementation of the
Black Sea grain initiative
since its launch 362 vessels with 8
million tons of food products on board
left Ukrainian ports for the countries
of Asia Europe and Africa
Ukraine continues working with the UN
world food program to increase the
amount of food sent to the most
vulnerable countries
in particular on the 18th of October the
sixth bulk area under this program
arrives in the port of Journal Wars to
be further sent to Yemen
the expert of Ukrainian grain has
already contributed to the stabilization
of the global market
a decrease in prices and a reduction in
chaos caused by lack of food around the
world
we therefore support his extension after
the 22nd November when the initial 120
day period will expire
Mr President terrorist attacks by Russia
against Ukraine
only mobilize the International
Community to support Ukraine
even more and put even stronger pressure
on the terrorist state
each of the terrorists and war criminals
including war crimes suspects in this
very chamber
will be held accountable sooner or later
and the terrorist state will pay for
East Terror
pay with isolation
degradation and assets
Bulls of state and quasi-private
entities connected with these Russian
regime
but the world must react preventively
in order not to let kahovka or other
disaster happen
as president zielinski said yesterday in
his address to the nation
the principle of preventive response to
security threats should finally become
one of the basic principles of
international politics and I thank you
I thank the representative of Ukraine
for his statement I now give the flow to
the representative of Slovakia thank you
very much Mr President
Slovakia strongly condemns the ongoing
Russia's unprovoked and unjustified
military aggression against Ukraine
it is a clear sign of a strong violation
of the U.N Charter international law and
the rules based on International order
thank you for convening this meeting
it's important to continue focusing on
the situation in Ukraine
the fact that this Council has so far
failed to take decisive action on the
crisis on the war
should not stop us from focusing enough
on what is going on and in that context
I would like to thank and appreciate USG
di Carlo and Dresden coordinator Brown
and they are informative and important
briefings
we remain also as a neighboring country
of Ukraine Gravely concerned about the
humanitarian situation in Ukraine which
is today the focus of our discussion and
rightly so because if there is uh one
thing that should never sleep from our
attention it is the people who are
suffering this senseless War and who
needs to be heard and whose situation
needs to be addressed unfortunately it
progressively further deteriorates as we
have heard and this should not go
unnoticed older persons persons with
disabilities and other persons belonging
to marginalized groups and minorities
are affected also by the consequences of
this war facing a big trauma and are
even more likely to be exposed as
victims due to the higher risk of
devastating violation of their rights we
remain appalled by the huge numbers of
killings of innocent civilians attacks
on critical infrastructure as well as
the huge scale of sexual and
gender-based violence committed by
Russian Russian soldiers and occupants
thousands of people killed hundreds of
schools destroyed or damaged having
negative impact on children whose
fundamental right to education has been
breached as well as attacks on medical
facilities are only a short list of
consequences this madness caused due to
put in senseless decision to begin the
war
but the Russian Federation obviously
does not understand the phrase enough is
enough which was already
obtained by the Secretary General
we have witnessed in latest days another
slew of variety of missiles and Iranian
drones attacks to Target the cities in
Ukraine including Kiev nipro vinitsa and
Ivano francives in central Ukraine
zaporosia in the South and the kharkiv
and Sumi regions in the East among
others
we are particularly concerned about
attacks on energy infrastructure having
impact of on people's access to water
and heat which is particularly
disturbing with regard to coming winter
we are deeply concerned about the
serious effects of the Russian invasion
on Global Food security
we as we know millions of people around
the world are being pushed into extreme
poverty hunger and lack of access to
food and in that context we of course
fully support the
extension of the Black Sea grain
initiative
and safe passage of agricultural
delivery and shipping from Ukrainian
ports and we hope that this will be done
no one unfortunately can predict when
this senseless war will end and we
wanted it to be as soon as possible
but those who believe that by reaching a
truce silencing the guns everything
would be over or wrong
perpetrators of such highness attacks
like those in bucha Crema Turks
or quite recently in izum cannot remain
unpunished must and will be brought to
Justice
Slovakia recognizes Ukraine as an
independent sovereign state with
unquestionable territorial Integrity all
acts associated with the forcible
acquisition of Ukrainian territory by
the Russian Federation are now void and
illegitimate
the so-called referenda in the occupied
regions took place during an active
armed conflict in areas under Russian
occupation it cannot be called a true
expression of the will of the people
Slovakia will never recognize these
territories as anything but a part of
Ukraine
the voice of the United Nations from
last week was crystal clear
we have received a lot of questions from
our citizens from the media from young
people and the message needs to remain
clear
therefore we urge the Russian Federation
to fully implement the United Nations
General Assembly resolution of 12th of
October without further delay this is
the least that we can do for the people
of Ukraine for those suffering and for
the future of our planet I thank you Mr
President
I thank the representative of Slovakia
for his statement and I'll give the
floor to the representative of Germany
Mr President I thank you and I also
thank under Secretary General DiCarlo
and Resident coordinator Denise Brown
for their briefings
yet again they have made clear that
horrific consequences Russia's ongoing
aggression has
for the people of Ukraine and around the
world the world remains United for peace
143 countries have once again condemned
Russia's action demanded Russia to
respect the charter and to end its War
immediately and unconditionally
Russia's reaction to the word call for
peace is shocking over the last over
these last days it has escalated its
attacks deliberately and systematically
targeting civilian infrastructure
hundreds of missiles and drones
including drones supplied by Iran have
been hitting playgrounds residential
buildings schools hospitals Bridges and
power stations
Russia's aim is clear the Moscow regime
wants to subjugate Ukraine
it wants to plunge Ukraine quite
literally Into Darkness and make
Ukrainian trees knocking out electricity
and heating for millions of civilians
these attacks Violet International
humanitarian law and cup could amount to
war crimes those responsible for these
blatant violations of international law
will be held accountable
let me join colleagues in pointing out
that Russia is also violating resolution
2231.
yet another example of how Russia is
permanent member of this council's Fades
the U.N Charter all information we have
is quite clear the Iranian drones are
being used to terrorize civilians and
have been delivered to Russia without
prior approval by this Council and
therefore in blatant violation of
resolution 2231.
we are concerned and very much concerned
by reports that Iran also intends to
deliver ballistic missiles to Russia we
would welcome an investigation by the
U.N team responsible for monitoring the
implementation of 2231 and stand ready
to support the technical and partial
efforts
Mr President Germany will continue to
stand by the U.N Charter wherever in the
world is it is breached and we will
continue to stand by Ukraine We Stand
ready to support Ukraine in mitigating
the devastation caused by Russia's
attacks
this coming Tuesday a Chancellor Schultz
and president fonderlein will host the
international expert conference on the
recovery reconstruction and
modernization of Ukraine in Berlin this
conference will Galvanize international
support for Ukraine's recovery and
reconstruction
to conclude Mr President
the Russian Federation must change its
course fully respect the letter and
spirit of the U.N Charter and withdrawal
from Ukraine it must comply with the
legally binding order of the
international court of justice to
immediately stop its military operations
against Ukraine and withdraw Germany
will continue to uphold the territory
integrity and political independence of
Ukraine within its International
recognized borders and this is the duty
of each and every one of us I thank you
I thank the representative of Germany
for her statement I now give the floor
to the representative of Poland
excellencies at the outset I uh thank
you Mr President for convening this
important briefing and also thank
today's briefers
for the available statements Poland
supports the written statement presented
for today's debate by Lithuania on
behalf of Lithuania Latvia Estonia and
Czech Republic
the main reason why we meet today again
in this chamber is Russia's deliberate
strategy to create a humanitarian
catastrophe in Ukraine by pursuing its
brutal War
and this war is regrettably far from
being over
the recent Kremlin decision on Military
immobilization and illegal annexations
of Ukrainian territories coupled with
nuclear rhetoric and mass airstrikes
against civilian infrastructure
indicates that Russia has chosen the
path of escalation
it has dramatic consequences not only
from in Ukraine but also for Global
Security and economic stability
including the dire situation on energy
markets and as well as the cost of
living crisis
Fierce Russians are attacked against
civilian targets launched on October
10th and following days and continued
since then are yet another violation of
international law
they seem to have the two purposes
Moscow wants to intimidate the civilian
population and to destroy Ukraine's
energy infrastructure which is critical
especially in the winter period
that's why uh the issue we need to focus
on immediately is the perspective of
upcoming winter
due to the Russian bombings over 3.5
million people are left without the roof
over their head
Mr President another immediate aspect to
the everyday life of people that we do
not discuss that often are the presence
of the explosive deliberately left
behind by the Russians does The
Challenge ahead of us in the mining of
the areas including agricultural lands
in various regions of Ukraine the mice
and exploited ordinance are a threat to
civilians including children
there is an urgent need to provide
adequate equipment to conduct these
operations
efficiently and quickly Mr President we
condemned in the strongest possible
terms recent missile attacks on
Ukrainian cities
shelling civilians is a war crime
civilians are not a Target civilians are
protected by international law including
Geneva conventions civilians must not be
taken hostages
Russian Federation has shown the total
lack of respect for the international
military and law and human rights law it
forces that committed horrific
atrocities
Poland will continue to work with
International institutions and Ukraine
to ensure that those responsible for
these barbaric acts are held accountable
opponent has constant consistently
supported Ukraine and its citizens in
the fight against the aggressor Poland
became a new home for over 1.3 million
refugees with who enjoy the same access
to public services and Social Security
benefits as public citizens we also help
those who stayed to to fight for their
country and cannot live by providing
government humanitarian Aid the only
appropriate response to Russian texts is
to increase the scale of our support for
Ukraine in that context let me Express
Polish Polish support for brave and
valuable work of the U.N team in Ukraine
Mr President I would like to emphasize
that the whole tragedy tragedy that this
enormous humanitarian crisis is purely
man-made there are no elements to blame
it is Russia who started the aggression
and under Russia Bears the full
responsibility for all the destructions
and laws of life it has caused the only
way it out in is peace
and for peace to come we need Russian
troops to be out of Ukraine
in his recent resolution U.N General
Assembly demanded Russia to reverse
course of attempted illegal annexation
143 member states strongly reaffirmed
Ukraine sovereignty and Terror Integrity
in his International recognized borders
this conference without any doubt that
no territorial concessions are expected
from Ukraine for peace to occur
despite this clear decision Russia
continues his path of escalation acts
against peace in Ukraine Mr President
Poland appeals to the members of this
Council and the whole International
Community to increase pressure on Russia
to stop this war
that would be an immediate almost
overnight solution to the whole crisis
Russia must immediately stop the
aggression we'll draw its troops and
abide to the rules of the U.N Charter
that equally applies to all
that would enable us all to start peace
building and to restore the shattered
lives and live foods of Ukrainian people
and we are ready to do so give peace a
chance
thank you
I thank the representative of Poland for
his statement I now give the floor to
his Excellency Mr olive school head of
the delegation of the European Union to
the United Nations
thank you for convening us thank you for
highlighting and organizing this meeting
it's very important that it be discussed
and it's very important that all
concerned are able to address the
Council on such an important issue Mr
President
two days ago the European Parliament
awarded the 2022 Sahara prize to the
people of Ukraine
for people who are safeguarding the
values of Freedom democracy and the rule
of law
people who have been forced to flee and
people who have sadly lost relatives and
friends there can be no more deserving
people of that kind of other recognition
Mr President we are appalled by Russia's
intensification of bombardments on
civilians and civilian facilities which
constitute serious violations of
international humanitarian law
this and last week's air attacks
deliberately targets critical
infrastructure and terrorized civilians
in Kiev and other Ukrainian cities
targeting civilians schools and energy
supplies can never be legitimate almost
a third of Ukraine's power stations have
been disabled Russia must be held
accountable for these evident violations
of international human return law that
are resulting in hundreds of Civilian
casualties every week
the same goes for those who facilitate
the aggression Belarus and Iran
we strongly condemn the clandestine
transfer of combat drones by Iran to
Russia
without seeking the security council's
prior approval which constitutes
material breach breach of security
Council resolution 2231.
the damage to Ukraine's energy
infrastructure is creating major
challenges in view of the upcoming
winter and will require stepping up the
international humanitarian response
during his visit in Kiev this week EU
commissioner and archic announced the
mobilization of an additional
175 million euros in humanitarian
funding to address urgent needs and
provide education food access to water
and protection from the cold winter
however no level of humanitarian funding
will be enough if Russian attacks
continue to Target energy infrastructure
and heating stations
more than 400 of these have been damaged
in the past two weeks alone the Russian
Federation must immediately stop its
attacks suspend its military operations
in the territory of Ukraine and we draw
all its military forces armed groups and
other unauthorized Personnel from the
territory of Ukraine as has been set out
by General General Assembly
we know that humanitarian needs in
Ukraine are immense and growing yet we
cannot even assess their scale in the
non-government-controlled areas on
Wednesday we heard a plea from the U.N
resident coordinator access must be
given to humanitarian organizations
immediately so that they can assist all
vulnerable people in Ukraine without
distinction this is not about politics
it is humanitarian imperative
we are devastated by the repeated
discoveries of atrocities in liberated
areas and the increasing horrific number
of Civilian casualties across the
country
where the Russian armed forces have been
minefields are left behind making
delivery of humanitarian assistance
impossible and endangering the lives of
innocent people
shocking are reports of arbitrary
executions and detentions rape torture
and other ill treatment unlawful
forcible transfers and deportations of
Ukrainian civilians including children
within territories under Russian
military control to Russia
we note that the un independent
International Commission of inquiry on
Ukraine concluded based on the evidence
gathered in the regions of Kiev
chernitiv karkid and Sumi that
atrocities to be classified as war
crimes have been committed in Ukraine
we stress the importance of collecting
consolidating and analyzing evidence of
violations and abuses of Human Rights
and violations of IHL and related crimes
committed in the context of Russia's
aggression against Ukraine and we
support measures to ensure
accountability including investigations
by the prosecutor of the international
criminal court
we also underlined that all
International and Regional
accountability and monitoring mechanisms
should be granted full secure and
unrestricted access to the entire church
of Ukraine including to all war related
detainees
we therefore urge the Russian Federation
to comply with the appeal of the
Secretary General to Grant the
international Committee of the Red Cross
full access to all prisoners of War
the release of over 100 Ukrainian women
which took place on 17th of October is
an important step in the right direction
Mr President Russia's unprovoked
unjustified an illegal war of aggression
against Ukraine has created a
humanitarian crisis that is also having
devastating Global impacts the
deliberate destruction by Russia of
Ukraine's agricultural transport
infrastructure is causing worldwide food
supply chain disruptions and endangers
the food security of millions of people
around the globe in this context the
Black Sea grain initiative is of a key
importance to mitigate the global impact
of Russia's aggression and we support
the call by the Secretary General
Antonio Gutierrez to extend it Beyond
November 19. thank you very much Mr
President
traveled to Kiev on Wednesday under
well-known extraordinary circumstances
being the only visit taking place within
these Troublesome period Kiev as the
rest of the country is on a daily basis
under this use attacks resulting
um in the death and injury of dozens
dozens of unarmed innocent people this
is the third visit of minister edendias
in Ukraine since the beginning of the
war as he has visited Odessa twice a
city connected with Greek history and
the Greek community of Ukraine these
visits send a strong message expressing
the full solidarity of the Greek
government to the government and the
people of Ukraine
for centuries Greeks have been present
especially on the Black Sea Shores in
particular the area of Mario Paul has
been a home to a century-long
established Greek community of around a
hundred thousand people it is also one
of the areas which have been hit the
hardest by the Russian forces the city
of Mario Paul has been almost entirely
destroyed for Greece respect for
international law for the territorial
integrity and sovereignty of all
countries is the pillar of our foreign
policy and for that from day one we
condemned the Russian invasion of
Ukraine recent Horizon attacks carried
out by drones are having far-reaching
repercussions affecting directly vital
civil infrastructure leading to an
inhuman and continuous and merciless
selling targeting innocent lives Greece
condemns these attacks in the strongest
of terms we have repeatedly asked for
irritant compliance with International
humanitarian law for the protection of
civilians and their property
safeguarding the right of safe passage
from conflict zones across the valid
zones access to valid information
concerning areas of safe temporary
shelter as well as humanitarian access
to areas where civilians continue to
reside grease is providing humanitarian
aid from the very start of the world we
have so far delivered multiple packages
of needs based in kind humanitarian
assistance furthermore we are firmly
engaged to the Reconstruction of Ukraine
we have announced that we are ready to
rebuild a maternity hospital destroyed
by Russian sailing in the city of Mario
Paul and to contribute to the
Reconstruction of Odessa and other City
close to a heart for us since our
struggle for Independence began there
and we are ready and working together
for the promotion of the candidacy of
the historic Center of Odessa for
inscription on the UNESCO world heritage
list given my country's particular
sensitivity regarding children we have
pledged 20 100
000 Euros to unicef's humanitarian
action in UK grain furthermore we have
taken over the treatment of children
with cancer at the oncologic hospital
for children alpida who means hope
also we responded effectively to the
needs of tens of thousands of Ukrainian
citizens seeking Refuge Refuge from the
war having welcomed more than 75
um
thousand refugees including uncompanied
minors unfortunately separated from the
families from Ukraine eligible to
immediate protection
a call center has been set up to
facilitate communication of displaced
persons from Ukraine with detailed
information provided in Greek English
and Ukrainian
actions on education level have also
been into effect to ensure the inclusion
of Ukrainian pupils
at the same time through our commercial
Fleet we contribute to the transfer of
Ukrainian grain towards keyports in the
North African region in an effort to
face food crisis
Grace is always is also strongly
committed to accountability for war
crimes Minister then yes has sent
relevant letter to the prosecutor of the
international criminal court and in this
respect visited the hug
no matter all the efforts of the
International Community the only real
solution to the ongoing suffering of the
Ukrainian people is the immediate
cessation of the unprovoked aggression
on the part of Russia thank you
I thank the representative of Greece
are no more speakers on the speaker's
list
the meeting is adjourned
amazing
stick out that's it
okay
in fact when
I was told
foreign
tomorrow night
tomorrow
foreign
oh yeah
this is the secondary audio circuit for
the Reuters live service
this is the secondary audio circuit for
the Reuters live service
this is the secondary audio circuit for
the Reuters live service